it's hard to believe but animal crossing
new horizons turns
one this week and some of you out there
are probably asking is it too late for
new players to get in on all the fun
the short answer absolutely not in fact
it's actually a great time to get
started and in today's video i'll give
you five reasons why it's not too late
to start animal crossing new horizons
people love the internet retro rack and
tour here if we're meeting for the first
time i'm just a dad who loves games and
the stories they tell we post videos
every week here on youtube and would
love to have you as part of our growing
community
here in fact i know a lot of the loyal
viewers are big animal crossing players
so i need to hear from you guys as well
make sure you let me know down in the
comments what are some reasons that
folks should start playing animal
crossing now
even if they've never played before as
for my five reasons
let's dive in number one events from
will return so one of the biggest
reasons that now is still a great time
to get started in animal crossing is the
fact that special events
repeat themselves that's right anything
you heard about your friends enjoying
throughout animal crossing in 2020
will be back in 2021 and to be honest
with you you could actually go back and
relive 2020 if you wanted to
at least within animal crossing
hopefully not in the real world
in fact it's always been this way in
animal crossing games if you're
relatively new to the series or looking
to jump in for the first time then you
may have a few misconceptions as to how
the game's calendar and time system work
you might be under the impression the
game requires an internet connection and
has special events
only made possible through updates made
from nintendo
but that's only partly true to
understand this we'll need to do a
little time traveling ourselves and go
back to when animal crossing got its
start which was on the nintendo gamecube
there animal crossing had a real world
day and night
time system there was no online support
for animal crossing on the gamecube so
how did nintendo have this ongoing world
that felt like things were changing from
day to day and also have special events
around holidays
and character birthdays it's actually
quite simple and rather brilliant for
its time
the game simply looked at the gamecube's
internal clock
for example when the gamecube's internal
clock was set to october 31st then
animal crossing would match that in-game
halloween festivities included
it didn't take long for players to
realize you could essentially time
travel within animal crossing to any day
and any time by changing your system's
internal clock
now personally i don't really like
playing with time travel i prefer to
kind of experience the game
organically and naturally but there are
plenty of folks out there who do
time travel so if there's a specific
event you really want to see in new
horizons then you can certainly do that
by changing the switch's internal clock
there are some weird issues that can
happen with items when you're traveling
back and forth in time so just make sure
you read up on it in more detail before
trying it
especially if you have any turnips
you're waiting to sell
but whether you're a time traveler or
not if you're thinking you'd miss all
the holidays and festivities that took
place in 2020 and new horizons
well you're in luck because those events
will happen again
this year in 2020 fishing tournaments
bug offs halloween toy day and more will
all happen again
but and here's where the differences
come in you will need to make sure you
update the game first to experience
everything you see that's where things
with new horizons start to differ a bit
from the way they originally were on the
gamecube
with the gamecube all these recurring
events were pre-programmed into the game
itself and then triggered by the
system's internal clock
new horizons was a little different in
that it shipped with some events and
special days but nintendo has issued
frequent online updates to add even more
to the game
at the time of this recording they're on
version 1.8
you can see everything they've added
along the way by looking through the
animal crossing wiki which i will link
to down
in the description there are some out
there who believe nintendo took this new
approach to prevent people from being
able to time travel
instantly and experience all of the
special holidays in the game
but now that we've finished a full
calendar year with all those updates you
can actually go back and jump to any of
those
or experience them again this year
nintendo is also planning to add
even more throughout the year but more
on that later
what's great about the updates overall
is that they aren't special one-time
events that will never come back
anything that's been added so far you
can experience right away by either
waiting to the correct day and time
or time travel of course this would
require you to update your game to the
latest version
some of the updates they've done along
the way included adding sea creatures
deep sea diving
new vendors special events and more the
most recent update added mario themed
items to the game and then right around
the corner we've got hello kitty themed
items coming to animal crossing as well
so technically online isn't required to
play the game but you'll probably want
to connect at least
one time to make sure you get those
updates which all to this point have
been free
now if you guys are completely new to
animal crossing or thinking about
getting started let me know what
questions you have down in the comments
below i have a full playlist for
beginners i'll link to here at the end
of the video but let's get on to number
two now which
is more updates now just to continue our
conversation with updates nintendo
apparently
isn't done i'm recording this video just
a few days before the one year
anniversary of new horizons release and
it still seems nintendo was planning to
release
regular content updates throughout this
year and again so far they've all been
in the form of
free updates the most recent update came
on february 25th this update brought new
mario themed items to the game that were
added to the nook shopping app
later on march 1st and by the time you
see this video it is very possible that
the sanrio crossover featuring hello
kitty themed items has already taken
place
as well with animal crossing being a
best seller for nintendo i think it's
highly likely that they'll continue to
work
keeping the game updated and fresh
throughout 2021
who knows if the updates will be as
frequent or significant but there are
definitely some fan favorite characters
and locations who still haven't been
added to the game
number three a huge and still growing
player base another reason why now here
is still a great time to jump into the
game is its ever-growing player base
animal crossing new horizons continues
to be a top seller even a full year
after its initial release and while you
can enjoy new horizons completely on
your own having fellow players to visit
and trade items with can make the
experience
even better you'll also be able to make
money faster by gathering non-native
fruits from other islands and bringing
them back to plant
and eventually sell on your own island
just make sure you ask for permission
before you start taking anything from
someone else's island though or else you
might get kicked out
there are also folks out there who have
devised special co-op games to play when
visiting each other such as sumo
wrestling or hide and seek
and many many more nintendo also added
in the dream suite which is a feature
where you can visit someone's island
even without them being online at the
time it's a little more of a contained
experience and you don't have the same
options as if you were visiting their
island in real time but it's still a
great way to check out a friend's island
and maybe get some design inspiration
now quick important note here to visit a
friend's island or have a friend
visit you it does require a nintendo
online account which is a paid account
at this point
so in order to be able to experience
that you would have to be a nintendo
online member
and at number four we have design ideas
so many design ideas guys because
of the fact that the game has been out
for nearly a full calendar year there
are plenty of places to look for tips
advice and inspiration like hopefully
this channel there are a number of
fantastic youtube channels subreddits
and discords dedicated to animal
crossing design ideas
in my opinion this is where animal
crossing shines the brightest i am
constantly amazed by this community and
their level of creativity when it comes
to custom designs home layouts island
layouts and decorations
thanks to the addition of terraforming
and new horizons you can truly shape
your island as you see fit
to be honest designing special areas of
my island around different themes has
been one of my favorite things to do in
new horizons
i got the game back at launch and still
haven't even put much time into
decorating my house because i've spent
so much time and energy worried about
the overall design of my island instead
if you care more about your home though
that's also an enjoyable endeavor with
plenty of design
inspiration available online number five
on our list we have
longevity you see animal crossing as a
series has always had this special sense
of timelessness to it
there are plenty of people out there
even today who still check in on their
old gamecube islands or with animal
crossing wild world or new leaf
some people check all three of them if
the game clicks with you in the right
way then it could be one of those games
where you play occasionally off and on
for years to come
keep in mind it's a game that never
forces you or hers you on to another
challenge or checkpoint you can enjoy it
at your own pace and focus on tasks that
matter to you you can go after the
golden fishing rod by trying to catch
all the fish
you can work to complete your museum you
can try and breed every flower in the
game
or you can simply focus on making your
home the coziest spot imaginable
it's all up to you and new horizons will
let you play how you want to play
if you guys have any questions at all
about getting started with animal
crossing let me know in the comments and
don't forget to check out that beginner
playlist which you should see now
on the right side of your screen as
always thank you all so much for
watching
i'll talk to you again soon